hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and uh Happy fed day hope everyone had
some fun today in the markets you know I
was pretty crazy afternoon once the FED
came out but uh you know in the morning
going into the FED
um meeting you know it's very quiet
session you can see here you know
basically we're trading between you know
85 and you know 95 more or less and then
when obviously the announcement came out
uh Market sold off immediately but uh
you know as a normal seems like the new
uh Joe Biden era by Dynamics you know
when you have something that should be
bearish for the market instead of Market
rally the market rallied up to new highs
um I believe it was what 39-25 ish or
thereabouts and then it sold off which
it should have initially should have
just kept selling off but um you know it
was just really interesting in the order
flow now
people always ask you know gosh you know
how do you trade these fed days well one
you know if you don't have to trade stay
away from them but you know if you're a
junkie an addict and you know you like
the action because fed days really give
you a lot of action it's a snoozer up
until uh one o'clock and then the
fireworks happen but you know the one
thing that I learned very early on in on
in the uh in the on the trading floor
the CME is you know on these fed days
it'd be interesting because uh I
remember my I'll say my mentor but the
the lady that taught me a lot Donna she
you know had been on the Board of Trade
on the CME and she says you know look
what happens when the FED announcements
come out right it's the retail reaction
right the big Traders they're just
sitting back right there waiting for the
market to settle down and
you know once the Market's settled down
you got that big Trend down and on a day
like today which you know is going to be
volatile after the announcement comes
out
um you know anything inflation related
you know CPI obviously fed announcements
then you know you're expecting some
fireworks and if you're trying to trade
on on a one minute chart
you're getting some massive bars you
know you've seen a lot of volatility
coming to the market this is a simple
one minute you know footprint chart and
you know you're looking at bars that are
I mean obvious you know take away the
bar that's on you know the first two
bars after the announcement
but afterwards you know you're looking
at bars that are you know
15 20 handles okay I don't like to look
at bars that are 15 or 20 Handles in the
e-minis you know NASDAQ and it's kind of
normal but uh you know in the e-minis I
prefer something that's manageable and
on more volatile days or
you know market conditions that are
volatile obviously you know if CPI comes
out it's one of those days fed day comes
out I go to a smaller time frame you
know I try to
take advantage of what's happening right
now I mean really with order flow the
strength is in reacting to what's
happening now and on volatile days if
you're on a minute chart you're way
behind and I like to go down to a 30
second chart I mean that doesn't
necessarily reduce you know the risk
because obviously you don't want to take
every trade
and try to run it for as much as it can
but it can reverse on you just as fast
you know as any other chart so you know
again you know going up into the FED
announcement you know very quiet and
snoozer you know it's one of those
things you're just sitting around
twiddling your thumbs waiting for
you know waiting for the fireworks to
happen sorry about that
um
and let's be honest you and me were not
economists I mean especially I don't
claim to be some fancy guy oh yeah you
know this is what is going to happen in
the macro environment Etc heck when I
worked at JP Morgan's Morgan you know we
had an economist there
um this is Dave Fernandez you know he
was like you know he was The Economist
he was the guy that always goes on CNBC
you know and if you look at his his bio
you know I could see it internally but
you know if you go to his LinkedIn page
you know he did his uh PhD his advisor
was uh Ben Bernanke so you know these
guys that are economists yeah leave that
stuff up to them we're Traders we trade
all right forget that economic Mumble
jumbo what's happening in the market how
can we trade it okay so the number came
out what I like to look for okay I'll
just call it up front it's real simple
look for those imbalances coming into
the market
precisely stacked imbalances okay I'm
not necessarily so concerned with
multiple imbalances because I know
there's going to be multiple imbalances
pretty much in every single bar because
there's a lot of volatility but what I
like to look for on volatile days or
volatile situations is stacked
imbalances because it's often the result
of a big order hitting the market buy me
750 e-minis sell me 1200 e-minis boom
you know and they're just
orders that aren't like oh sit there and
try and finesse it because the Market's
moving so fast that the execution desk
right the Traders on the execution desk
no they better get this order filled
otherwise you know the Market's going to
be trading 10 points higher or 10 points
lower
right so if they're trying to buy 1200
e-minis
and the Market's trading you know
38.90 and they're trying to finesse it
then
they just finesse themselves out of
getting any more orders from you know
that that PM because
they've screwed it up right they should
have got filled probably around 38.92
because the order came in it was trading
38.90 next thing you know it's trading
you know 39.05 10 points higher
so by going to a shorter term chart so
to speak you know a 30 second chart from
a one minute when things are volatile
and looking for
um stacked imbalances really what I'm
trying to take advantage of are those
big orders coming into the market
okay so again you know you're not going
to trade probably the first three or
four minutes after the announcement that
comes out just because it's just too
freaking volatile right I mean who's
who's going to trade on
pet announced something you know you
could be as fast as you want right have
your order queued up ready to press
enter
but how those hfts that are co-located
right next to the exchange are they're
going to be ahead of you
you know they're half a milliseconds
you're maybe as close as you can get you
and me can get is probably five or ten
all right so thinking you're gonna be
very fast by sitting in you know on your
at home trying to hit the enter button
you're going to be very late right
you're gonna be very very late so you
can see obviously it dropped from you
know the the 39.05 immediately down to
70 okay but you know but then it starts
settling down and really you know again
this is a 30 second chart what I'm
looking for are
buying or selling the balances okay sort
of going with them
so they're selling a balance here okay
selling a balance here Market rally back
up
now when I see stuff like this okay
to me you know this is these guys are
stuck they're trapped I don't like to
just oh there's there's an imbalance I
gotta go trade it right I I will watch
the order flow right I mean I can give
you
um I'm just telling you you look for
those stacked imbalances as a result of
a big order but generally the volume
will fill in but if these things are
just hanging up there
right if I got a big stacked imbalance
and the market rallies back up and then
it starts trading back down I see
selling imbalances coming into it and if
we're going to take out that imbalance
again yeah I'm going to get short
right it's not just oh there's a selling
and balance get short
no
let the market tell you that yeah you
know there's continued buying
right
when I see something like this this is
what I call an inverse imbalance all
right it's a stack selling a balance at
the bottom of a green bar right and
these guys are these guys are stuck this
is what trap Traders look like
um I mean it could have been just the
stop that got triggered here most likely
but the market reacted back up when I
see something like this you know to me
this is a great little scalping
opportunity to get long as soon as this
bar starts turning green it starts
trading higher that's my cue to get long
um but again it's not on a volatile day
I'm not necessarily I'm in and out I'm
in and out right it's not one that
you're going to be looking to
right although there are some nice
Trends you know on the day like today
you just uh I don't know you got to be
you got to be careful everyone trades
differently here's a nice stack buying
imbalance okay but it didn't continue
Market came right back down still green
I'm just waiting for the retest to come
back up take that out right we took it
out right here boom right went higher
all right here's a nice stack buying
imbalance right we traded all the way up
here right bet and balance came back at
uh 57 okay but then you know we couldn't
really we we went higher in this bar but
we couldn't build on it then the next
bar trades right down into it right not
a good sign
um what else we got in here okay
it's a nice stack buying and balance you
know I'd prefer to see
yeah
yeah I've done analysis on where the
Stacked and balance occurs in a bar if
it's you know in the middle at top at
the bottom is there any significance to
it
not really I honestly I didn't really
find anything okay I wish there was
something I wish I could say yeah you
know what you got a stacked imbalance at
the top of a green bar go with it
yeah it's not as simple as that
I like to just you know okay I got that
stacked in balance
wait for the market just sort of keep
going in in that direction in the next
bar or two just like here right stacked
in Balance nothing happened but then the
buying reappeared and got through it
that's what I'm getting long just like
this one here right we closed up here
Mark came back pulled back then came
back up through it and you got another
you know you got some more points out of
it here's a nice stacked imbalance
again Market came back down it wasn't
until this bar this is the bar you
should be getting long you know 55-ish
area
shot up to 60.
okay there's a couple buying imbalances
it looked like it was going to run you
ran later didn't run here and just sort
of came back down
you know here's a couple more buying and
balance you know there's a stack selling
imbalance
what lower okay not much lower but again
on volatile day like this I just find it
easier to scalp rather than trying to
take you know this is my position I lose
my Hill I'm gonna die on I know there's
volatility so I know there's going to be
plenty of opportunities I don't kick
myself that oh I only made you know two
points three points on this move
when you when you see other moves making
20 30 points because you know I know I'm
gonna get plenty of opportunities right
I'd rather get the base hits rather than
hit the Home Run and a lot of strikeouts
um you know another thing you know that
I I tested out a little bit but you know
I
bars that have multiple imbalances
multiple stacked imbalances like this
one this one this one
theoretically you know you think well
there's a lot of buying pressure in
there it should be a stronger signal
yeah yes and no I mean I I didn't find
anything really
I mean yeah the markets tend to continue
moving there but you know it wasn't like
an 80 win rate or something like that on
getting them I mean it was okay but you
still got to manage your trades I mean
it's a great directional
um clue
obviously stack buying a balance but
again look at these volumes in 17 19 17
it's quite small that just gives you an
idea of the volatility that's that's
taking place here
um okay so anyway we went up rallied
all the way up is this the one where we
got all the way up to no that's not the
move but again you're getting the idea
right look for those imbalances look for
the continuations in the next bar
okay so anyway we got all the way up in
here
these new highs new highs new highs
um
up here at these highs you know I did
have a reference based off of value
areas from earlier right around this 25
um but you know again it got up towards
these highs now all of a sudden you're
seeing the selling coming in I mean
decent selling you're up here at a high
strong negative Delta 858 minus 900
minus 1100 as you make that High I mean
earlier yeah there are some bars with
some negative Deltas coming in here
trading much lower obviously but you
know minus a thousand down here
way down here
um but it shot back up right so anyway
we're at the highs of these days new
highs of the day
right and I've talked I've been talking
about this for a while when you're at
new highs of the day especially late in
the session watch for
selling coming in
you can see the selling coming in here
all right you're not seeing the buying
anymore now I didn't expect this move to
be so dramatic
on the sell-off
but it just took off man I mean you see
in right up in here right the high at 25
and a quarter you know you got these
buying imbalances here I'd hate to be
that guy that bought this high up here
you know there's 8 to 136 these
imbalances they're just
yeah hopefully they got out at least 10
points lower rather than you know 100
points lower but um you know as we're
coming down we're starting to see these
selling imbalances right on the way up
buying imbalances obviously on the way
down selling imbalances
okay
we're seeing in here some binding
balances no follow-through this inverse
imbalance which is actually bullish
um
no follow-through here in the next bar
right you're just sort of going sideways
with the point of controls more or less
lined up we sort of make another run
back up here then you're seeing selling
a balance now here's the Trap Traders
one where it uh kind of paid off quite
nicely
you know on our order flows Trader
software
good news we're going to be doing an
upgrade releasing the new upgrade
um by in a few weeks and
there's some nice changes in there
uh inverse imbalance here I have it
turned off but I'll turn it on
it's going to show you these areas where
these these trap Traders and but anyway
on on the new version of order flows
Trader 6 you're going to be telling my
programmer when he sent me over the copy
it is like
the difference of watching a black and
white television versus watching a color
television and um
you know so anyone that's got the
this version of order flows Trader or
previous version of overflows Trader the
upgrade is is no no cost all right so
you don't have to you know some people
they like to have really software then
do an upgrade and charge you for the
upgrade
um Microsoft but uh
you know we don't we don't do that so as
long as you get in
future upgrades are no cost so here
right you can see it's and before it was
red now it's blue because we call this
an inverse imbalance this is bullish
and you see you got a nice move up right
people say well it's only uh you know
it's not a big move well it's a move
from you know the O2 oh two and a half
area up to you know 08 I mean to get up
to up here but you know realistically
you know two up to six seven you know
that's five points
right here's a bearish one right this
dark red right it's blue for bullish
dark red for bearish and this one is
just like
started selling off keeps coming back in
here it keeps coming back up into that
area and then obviously
the market just fell over right and I
mean these moves this is a 30 second
chart look at some of these bars how the
volatility 75 up to 89 on a 30 second
chart
scandalous at least but um but you know
that's what the Market's going to do
so yeah again yeah look at those stacked
imbalances there's plenty of ways to
take advantage of them you know I like
to see them and sort of trade in the
direction if they're coming in
you know they're coming in here right I
get short in this bar you know
there's another stacked in Balance I
could be getting short in this bar
there's just a lot of opportunities with
stacked imbalances because oftentimes
it's just the result of a big order that
needs to be executed fast right I mean
you know when tutor calls the execution
desk hey sell me 1200 e-minis just get
it done
the execution trigger is not going to
dick around because he knows if he
screws up the order tutor's going to put
him in the The Penalty Box not give them
any more orders so you're just going to
get it done and on a market that's
selling off yeah sell me you know 500 s
PS done okay next thing you know you you
sold your 500 at uh you know Marcus
trading 85 you sold your 500 down to 84
then the Market's trading 80. you're
looking golden right because you know
this Market is is moving
so anyway guys
I hope you guys got something of value
out of this video be sure to like And
subscribe
to my channel like the video subscribe
to the channel and you know again thanks
for taking the time out of your day to
watch uh one of my videos bye bye